hey guys why is discipline so important
so crucial in a man's
life because if you don't have
self-control what makes you different
from an animal that only lives according
to its urges and desires wise men are
extremely disciplined in every aspect of
their lives because they understand that
they need to sacrifice temporary things
and wants desires you know in order to
achieve what they want most in life
Hebrews 12:11 says for the moment all
discipline seems painful rather than
pleasant but later it yields the
peaceful fruit of righteousness to those
who have been trained by
it you know your feelings your emotions
are good to have you know on one end but
on the other end is like a two edged
sword you know because it can cut inward
as well it can give you Joy and those
kind of feelings but when it cuts inward
you know it can make you crave things
that you know are actually not good for
you in the long term and that's where
discipline comes in for example you
might not feel like studying now to
become a doctor later which is what you
really want or you might not feel like
eating healthy and working out now
to get a good body later but that is
what you really
want so you discipline yourself in every
area of your life
especially when you know those times
where you experience temporary things
that you don't really want to do you
feel it in your show like man I don't
really want to do this I don't feel like
it but you do it anyway you sacrifice
that part of your life right you're like
man I'm going to do what needs to be
done even if I don't like it I'm going
to endure it so that I can go through
this part of my life that's temporary
and Achieve that which what I want most
in my life so you need to discipline
yourself to have self-control Paul said
in 1 Corinthians 9 do you not know that
in a race all the runners run but only
one receives the prize so run that you
may obtain it every athlete exercises
selfcontrol in all things they do it to
receive a perishable wreath but we an
imperishable so I do not run aimlessly I
do not box as one beating the air but I
discipline my body and keep it under
control lest after preaching to others I
myself should be
disqualified now how can you be more
disciplined you probably think well well
I have to do this and this and this and
this and that's where you're wrong it's
not about you you have to do
nothing let me explain you have to do
nothing in your own little human power
because by yourself on your own you can
accomplish nothing you cannot have
effective 100% self-control in every
aspect of your life if you try to do it
by yourself because you are the problem
Jesus said in John 15:5 life I am the
vine you are the branches whoever abides
in me and I in him he it is that bears
much fruit for apart from me you can do
nothing do you get it one of the fruit
of the spirit is self-control so if you
live through the spirit the power of the
Holy Spirit then you will be able to
produce the fruit of the spirit and one
of them is self self-control and this is
not your own power on your soul level it
is a spiritual power Galatians
5:22 but the fruit of the spirit is love
joy peace patience kindness goodness
faithfulness gentleness here it comes
selfcontrol
against such things there is no law so
if you're a reborn Christian and you say
well I don't have
self-control then in a sense you're
right because we all have that sinful
fleshly nature within us and it's going
to be there until the day we die and it
pushes us to do sin like overeating
gluttony getting angry and quarrel or
not study but be lazy it is that fleshly
nature within you that brings you
down but you see if you are a true
reborn Christian you have received a new
spiritual nature God himself the Holy
Spirit came and live inside of you you
see there is a change and now you can
choose to live through the spirit and
the spirit can overcome the Flesh and it
is the only Power that can overcome the
sinful nature because you cannot
overcome it because it is in you you are
the problem it is your emotions it is
your desires that is pushing you to do
things that you don't really want to do
and later you regret and you're like man
why did I do this is because of the
sinful nature within you and some people
they get frustrated they get they get
angry you know and sad because man they
don't understand themselves anymore why
do they keep on doing things which they
regret later and it seems like they they
can't have any
self-control some even get afraid
because they don't know what to do but
two Timothy 1:7 says for God gave us a
spirit not of fear but of power power
and love and selfcontrol
if you want to be more disciplined if
you do it on your your own little human
power that level just on your soul level
you know you can try to do it to some
degree but you will always reach that
area where you're
stuck but you can do it through the
spirit that is in you so if you want to
learn how to discipline yourself grow in
Christ he is the answer living through
the spirit that is the key when you
start growing in Christ you learn truth
you start to understand the truth you
write it on your heart you start to live
it and then everything change especially
having self discipline because now
you're not on your own you're not
struggling through life you understand a
bigger picture of life you open the tap
to let the power of God flow through you
the Holy Spirit and you just follow him
Philippians
4:13 I can do all things through him who
strengthens
me you know certain people ask me
sometimes Daniel how are you
so determined you know how do you have
selfcontrol well it's not me it's all
because of God when I was younger I
struggled with self-discipline believe
it or not until God revealed himself to
me I accepted him as Lord and Savior and
then I started to grow spiritually Jesus
also talks about those of little faith
but you can grow in your faith and that
is what makes you stronger it is God
that teaches us how to have
self-discipline to control our thoughts
to take all those thoughts capture you
know and bring it under the lordship of
Jesus Christ it is he that helped me to
control my thoughts my body my actions
everything and he can help you too if
you ask him Proverbs 12:1 whoever loves
discipline loves knowledge but he who
hates reprove is
stupid now if you want to understand
this more especially the difference of
living through the spirit and not the
flesh then please get my free ebook I'll
add it for you in the video description
down
below and then you can also watch these
videos here and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys